so just going back real quickly to what
we're talking about earlier so you
didn't enter it in any screenplay
competitions but did you try to take it
up the like Hollywood food chain with an
agent or a manager you know no I know
that Melissa sent the script out you
know during right before production or
maybe pre-production just to sort of you
know see what the feedback was and we
had various you know kind of comments
about the script and I was able to weigh
what comments kind of helped us and what
didn't you know you know I think again
going back to what we talked about
earlier about being a real realistic
kind of road map for this you know trip
that we would be taking is really about
that because a lot of people came back
with notes like well you know that that
thing should really be happening on page
you know twelve not seven and that paid
that thing really doesn't make sense and
you know and I think a lot of the
comments like that are well-meaning
you know because I've written for many
many years and I think I understand all
that stuff but you know the conversation
that I had with Melissa that we had to
really negotiate was this project is
really about a certain you know location
a certain budget a certain kind of
vision with with in terms of scheduling
you know and so we really had to be be
wise about what what feedback we wanted
to take and what feedback we wanted to
dismiss so we didn't take it up the
Hollywood food chain so to speak because
they just you know probably wouldn't be
interested because there are no car
chases and there's no kind of you know
there's no aliens or anything like that
you know it was really kind of a very
personal thing that we wanted to embark
on okay
did you implement any changes into the
script though when when they said this
is confusing here or maybe they didn't
say that did the two of you go back and
say well if we're getting feedback from
an outside source
maybe we're so close to it absolutely I
mean I I think I think that you know
we Melissa and I worked on outlining
this story from the very beginning we
were really trying to talk about the
characters talk about the relationship
talk about you know the plots the
narrative and all that stuff and themes
and everything and then once we had a
pretty fair idea of what story we wanted
to tell I went away and wrote the script
because I was gonna end up directing it
and I felt that it was really important
for me to be intimately involved with
with the nuts and bolts of it you know
and then once we got people kind of
looking at the script we absolutely you
know took in advice and comments about
it you know if that button is not funny
and a floor doesn't work or you know
that is an extra scene that you really
really don't need we absolutely did that
you know and also even you know like
like all films you know you essentially
rewrite the script in editing you know
you're writing your final draft and
editing and we have an amazing editor on
board who is really you know works on
bigger budget movies but he liked the
story he believed in it and so you know
me Melissa and Derek the three of us in
during editing really kind of tried to
reshape you know the story in some ways
to to match what we wanted to do you
know because there were still scenes
that we ended up not getting to you know
even even with the intention of shooting
a short script we still missed scenes
I'm sorry to interrupt but why well
because of budget because of time
because of schedule
you know it's an ensemble film so you're
working with a schedule of so many
different people and then there's the
budget part of it which is like we're
running out of time
that's gonna take an extra day so that
put us in in I mean it wasn't a horrible
situation I think the movie became
better but I do think that you know all
the feedback that you take you know you
have to take it from the very beginning
all the way to the end you know even in
editing we went through I don't know I
must have been three four different cuts
before we arrived at the final cut and
throughout the process you know we had a
very private you know kind of a
screening for about ten people on the
big screen
what are we invited people to come and
watch the movie and we got you know we
did a kind of a QA feedback you know we
gave him questionnaires and we said what
what movie what you know what part of
the movie did you enjoy and what do you
think about when you're done watching
this movie and and those questions and
the answers to those questions really
helped us you know gauge how far off we
were about our movie going back to what
you said earlier the best solution or
best answer usually wins in your opinion
something like that do you think a lot
of people are that open I mean no I
don't I don't think so and I think I
think I think even in some ways I missed
a mark you know because I do think that
you I think art you have to have an ego
in your story you know I don't think the
ego should get in the way but I do think
that you have to have an idea of what
your personal conviction is you know
what your vision is so I think being
mindful of it is is you know is I think
healthier then then a lot of people are
you know I mean I I like to believe that
I can always take a good note you know
it doesn't always happen and I think
that's true for everyone who's working
in this industry you know you have to
walk that line of
you personally feel like is right and
what the feedback is from different
people you know so it's it's a tough
it's a tough thing to kind of negotiate
you know I think it's um I think it's a
the context I think it yeah I think you
have to look at that in the context of
where the person is you know what are
the persons coming from you know yeah
I'm coming from another project that's
very similar so I have a certain
perspective and someone else is coming
from something else and so you have to
measure all of that you know yeah and
have a filter in terms of like what is
actually constructive criticism and what
is someone just biessing me and what is
somebody trying to squash me right and
it's a tough thing because I think in LA
or anything creative there's all those
coming at you right right so and I think
anybody who doesn't creative has a
fairly strong ego but then you can't be
a mouse either you can't just be like oh
really okay let me change that way you
know I mean you have to fight back a
little bit yeah
yeah absolutely absolutely
you